[Applause]
[Music]
sup y'all persley I don't know about you
guys I heard there's a lot of Brooklyn
people here right that makes me very
excited I live five blocks away from
here and I feel like there's not enough
tech happening in Brooklyn so it's
awesome to have you guys all here cool
so who here has heard of teachable show
of hands how bad
who here is a paying customer of
teachable there we go all right so
pretty good pretty good so today I want
to talk about the business behind
teachable specifically how we learned to
not entirely suck at growth so let's get
started so at the risk of sounding a
little bit douchey we had an amazing
November our creators some of whom are
here earned over 20 million dollars on
our platform we as a company made one
and a half million dollars in revenue
last month of which about eighty percent
of it came through monthly recurring
revenue which is our creators paying us
an average of $70 a creator a month or
our M RR which was 1.1 million dollars
so that looks pretty good right like
look at that graph look at how beautiful
we're gonna beautiful up into the right
it is it's very easy to look at this
graph and think everything was perfect
it was always rainbows and butterflies
and other beroun five things but no
that's not how it was like it wasn't
always that good twelve months in twelve
months after raising a billion dollars
in venture funding having a team of 10
people we were at only $10,000 in
monthly recurring revenue like things
were not working as well as they did
after that and we were pretty concerned
we were pretty concerned at the time
it's not that we were completely flat
what we were growing it was just very
very very slow like when you zoom in on
the first year like it again it looks up
and to the right but the fact is at
end of the day we were at only $10,000
in monthly recurring revenue after a
year and we were we didn't know what to
do we didn't know what we were not doing
right we read all the blog posts did all
the startup we were doing
everything it was just not working at
the scale we wanted to we could
basically afford one engineer kind of
that's our CTO Noah who probably doesn't
approve of me using his picture here we
could afford one person kind of one year
and with 10 people like the math was not
adding up we know what to do we were
working really hard we're working far
harder than than we frankly work now we
were hustling but it wasn't it wasn't
working like we were trying to grow as
fast as possible do everything we could
we were trying to follow the startup
today have you guys heard it do things
that don't scale we did all of that
stuff like I was personally like
uploading content for people we reached
out to Y Combinator and like hosted
their startup class on our website I was
manually I went to Ryan holiday took his
book we ourselves converted it to a
course to try and make the business work
we're doing all these things at once
scaling we even started growth hacking
which is a really stupid thing
don't growth hack I'm really happy that
word died and small side note on growth
hacking gross I grew basically just
trying to be smart asses about it and it
never worked one of the things we tried
is I thought it was really cool at the
time but I built this bought that
scraped all of you to me which was one
of our competitors was a marketplace had
other people telling courses so I built
this bought it scraped udemy it found
social media profiles for everyone who
had a course on udemy right so now I
have all these creators then I took
another database
cross-referenced it to get an email
address for every single udemy creator
which plugged into my gmail and it
automatically started emailing people to
check out teachable sounds cool right
you know what the stupid bug did it
email the founder of you to me that's
the first person it found it
the founder of you to me that's it
actually email it's like hey Gaga I
found you're teaching online awesome
check out fedora recall did not work
none of this stuff was working one year
in we were still at ten thousand dollars
in monthly recurring revenue but then we
16x the next year from 10,000 to 160,000
and that's what this talk is about it's
really the framework we applied and
that's what I'm gonna go over and
they'll the framework we apply to 16x
and the same framework that we still use
today that's what this is about so
here's what changed so we added a growth
model what we call the every dollar
model that has a picture of our team
member Andy who actually built this
model because I think a lot of founders
come up here and talk about all the
things the team members do as something
dated like this is not my creation this
is something a team member did and this
entire story by the way this entire
narrative is not my doing it's really
the team of people we have working there
I'm just here for my sense of humor my
good looks my tight t-shirts that's
that's the only reason I'm here to be
added in every dollar model with the
idea of being in the past actually
hopefully what we did in the past in the
past we had this epic Google spreadsheet
that was our growth idea backlog don't
take a photo of this this is the bad
stuff don't take a picture of this the
next thing is what you take photo of we
just had this epic list of all the ideas
we had that we wanted to work on we've
prioritized them had owners we worked
really hard to execute as many of them
as possible
our biggest metric then was how many of
these ideas can be complete in a single
month what we move to the every dollar
model which I will explain is we try to
account for every single dollar well
actually no we started by setting a
growth target work backwards and try to
account for every single dollar so the
easiest way to demonstrate this would be
to walk through a real example that we
used in August 20
team okay so the first big change we
made is we stopped trying to grow as
fast as possible
this sounds counterintuitive but what we
decided is we would pick a specific
number and at the time it was about 30%
was our desired growth rate month over
month we were highly intentional about
how fast we wanted to grow and then we
work backwards to figure out what that
looks like
so in August 2015 we wanted to grow 30%
we were starting at about $25,000 in M
our our our turn was sadly 12% then
which is really bad it's much much
better now but then we plugged this in
to some pretty basic math and figured
out what amount of revenue we needed to
add again this sounds obvious we went a
year and a half not doing this and I
guarantee there's a lot of people here
that don't go through this kind of
discipline so now our entire job becomes
really easy now instead of trying to
grow as fast as possible we have one
simple goal
ten thousand eight hundred forty three
dollars in new monthly recurring revenue
our marketing team our growths team had
one goal now one goal like the whole
thing became so much simpler and then we
would take this number and try and build
a bottom-up model and figure out where
it would come from so at the time we had
three things that were happening in
August we would get about $100 of
organic upgrades per day which should be
$3,100 but $3,000 in organic upgrades we
had weekly webinars to our free
customers that we gave an offer to
upgrade to a paid plan and that brought
in about $1,000 per Thursday and then we
were banking on an enterprise sale
closing right so with this we had eight
thousand dollars accounted for but
obviously there's a problem like we
still have to find twenty eight hundred
dollars in revenue and this happened
every single month this number we used
to call it the RTBF revenue to be found
this number is where we this number and
the necessity of hitting this number is
the single biggest reason we have
every single marketing strategy and
innovation that we have found has been
us trying to work backwards to hit this
RTBF number so I will I'll give you a
few examples of how this apply to
different stages but it was really
applying this model figuring out how
fast we wanted to grow working backwards
to figure out what we already had
accounted for looking at the difference
and then focusing on how we make up the
difference sounds really simple but
that's been the single biggest reason
and the single biggest reason we
continue to grow so August for instance
we realized we could add in a few
partner promotions bring in affiliates
and do a promotion to them so for
instance we'll work with someone like
you know theoretically a Tim Ferriss or
obviously if a lower scale where they
will promote teachable to their audience
and that we can do three of those a
month and make up the three thousand
dollars so now we're going into August
2015 with some semblance of an idea as
to how we're going going to actually hit
these targets so the same way necessity
is the mother of all invention hitting
this RTBF number was where all of our
marketing strategy innovation came about
like in the past we were flying blind
trying to like work off this big list of
growth ideas but it wasn't as a
discipline there's like okay I need to
find two thousand eight hundred and
forty three dollars and I will do
whatever possible to find that amount
and at different stages we've made this
up in different ways right if you have
revenue be found of less than a thousand
dollars and by the way none of these
strategies are what I want you to take
away like you will have different
channels that work for you but just the
discipline of going through this
exercise but for us this is what worked
and under a thousand dollars direct
sales I could literally find enough
people email them and sell them myself
that's under three thousand dollars we
could do a big monthly webinar to all of
our three users make them an offer to
join a paid plan we could make up an
RTBF of three thousand dollars pretty
easily then five thousand dollars we had
to systematize it a little bit we had to
like add a weekly webinar we added a
weekly webinar on Thursdays and we added
one on Tuesdays and that reliably could
kind of add 5k in RTBF 10k again partner
promotions layer
on top of this help does hit the like
bigger RTBF number but at every single
stage as the numbers grew bigger we had
to keep innovating and find strategies
to actually hit this hit this goal so we
went inside into every month having some
idea of how we were gonna hit our goals
don't get me wrong we missed our goal 70
to 80 percent of the time but this
exercise of preparing ourselves and
coming up with a hypothesis for how
we're gonna hit our goals ultimately
fueled our entire growth engine so as
RTF increased so did our marketing
innovation here's a couple of specific
instances of things we found only
because of rtbf so a couple of years ago
we raised the price of our lowest here
which was our basic plan it used to be
$29 a month we moved it to $39 a month
and felt pretty good about it because we
added a lot of new features the plan was
better and we felt good that that was
gonna raise our average revenue per user
so in all the future months our organic
upgrades would be a higher amount the
problem with this is that wasn't gonna
help us hit gold this month we still had
a difference of about ten or fifteen
thousand dollars to make up this month
and the necessity of hitting that led to
us running a campaign where we offered
the old price to all of our existing
users for a one-week period just because
we needed to generate this like revenue
bump that specific month so we ran this
campaign it worked really really well
we added about $20,000 in EM RR for this
campaign and this is a strategy we've
reused about three to four times since
but the only reason we even found this
strategy was the necessity of hitting
this goal like the math wasn't adding up
so we had to try something that had a
chance in hell of hitting a five-figure
RTBF number another example is what we
call the summit but back in 2015 we had
to make up a lot of revenue one November
but we didn't we just didn't have time
to schedule enough partner promotions or
anything to make the whole thing work so
what we did and it was experimental the
time now
to become a pretty standard thing a lot
of companies do is we got about 15 or 20
partners and instead of doing one-off
promotions we created this massive event
where all 15 or 20 people are promoting
this one big event we're promoting it
we're trying to dot drive thousands of
people to this event and at the end of
the event we made a one-time offer to
buy a teachable plan and again this
whole thing when we tried it four years
ago was a massive experiment we're just
like we need to do something big like
the math is not adding up there's no
other way of hitting these numbers so we
did this summit back in 2015 and it
worked really well
we had a $25,000 in monthly recurring
revenue from this 2015 event but what's
cool about the summit is this is scaled
we did one two months ago and again our
numbers are higher now and we added a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
brand-new monthly recurring revenue from
this event like the scale is fully
different now we had 60,000 people sign
up we converted 2,000 paying customers
but the only reason we even found these
strategies was the necessity of hitting
a very very very specific rtbf goal so
necessity of hitting this is what led to
our very very best growth strategies and
the best part of this whole thing is the
accountability you get because as I
mentioned right like 70% of the times we
missed our goals but what was cool is
this quantitative model like this like
now we knew exactly why we missed it
like oh the enterprise sale never closed
and the partner promotions didn't work
that well so now I'm going to revise our
model were going into this with a lot
more data and I know this sounds some of
this sounds kind of obvious especially
for people that have never run a
software company we didn't do this for a
very long time there's companies I
advise and talk to that don't do this
it's sounds really simple but I've seen
far too many companies die despite
having arguably a more beautiful product
than us when we first started out like
better usability everything was better
but they succumb to the fallacy of
if you build it they will come we were
very very very very intentional about
all our growth ever since in the first
year we weren't but ever since then
we've applied this consistently and also
the corollary to this is it helped us
avoid what we call the great idea trap
an example is we've wanted to have a
conference call our creators call it
teach a con kind of make it like this
won't be as cool but definitely will
also be in Brooklyn but every time we
try to like spreadsheet this out and be
like what do we need to invest in terms
of like marketing team energy to pull it
off and what is their expected ROI you
could never prioritize it and there were
a lot of projects like this that when we
applied the the rigor and discipline of
a spreadsheet that again we're getting
the point where we don't have to have
every project have a positive ROI back
in the early days it was existential we
wouldn't be here if we weren't growing
so this discipline again it helped us
avoid so many ideas that we otherwise
would have pursued so this works really
really well till about 10 million
dollars in annual recurring revenue or
about $800,000 monthly recurring revenue
which was let's call it seven or eight
months ago it starts breaking down at
that scale a little bit just because
planning one or two months in advance
isn't good enough so we still use a
version of this right now it just has to
be a full year in advance where as you
can see these are real numbers we can't
do events all the time so we figure out
when we're going to do four or five
events a year load more growth into
those months kind of adjust for
seasonality we've got a little bit more
sophisticated about it like model or
churn rate going down and the goal of
this is now we have a target we need to
hit every single month we're doing a
full year in advance cuz we can
accordingly like now we have a finance
team we have like budgeting processes
there's all this other that you
four deal with so now we have to plan
this a year in advance but it's still a
version of the exact same thing we just
try and figure out when we're gonna push
well in time so we can hire for it
prepare for it and so forth and then
again
we have to work backwards right it's the
same exact thing there's just more
columns now there's just more channels
the other thing that changes is organic
becomes much more important because when
you have to add $200,000 and 180
thousand dollars and so forth unless
you're getting a good organic lift from
your existing customers the math doesn't
work out the other thing unique to where
we are now is as you can see there our
math is still not working out so sadly
even though the whole premise of this
talk is how we grew without paid next
year is when we have to learn how to
spend money if we want to still double
year-over-year which is our goal but
this stuff works and has worked for
yours and I strongly encourage everyone
here especially those running a software
company but if you're only an agency can
be applied if you're running most kinds
of businesses working backwards from
revenue and applying the every growth
model can absolutely work
so in conclusion right while we were
doing this a lot of people both
internally and externally thought this
was kind of dumb they thought that we
kept doing unsustainable things to hit a
local target but guess what if you do
something unsustainable repeatedly and
if you sustainably can do something
unsustainable for yours at a time there
is no difference between that and like
like that is a sustainable growth engine
our sustainable growth engine was
optimizing locally for months at a time
for years at a time until we built what
teachable is today so and this growth
again just I don't think it needs too
much for feeding but this growth is what
built momentum it got people excited
about the company
it built morale frankly like
operationally we were a disaster for
yours when you're growing 30 to 40
percent month on month that's fine like
people overlook a lot of stuff it helped
grow our brand it's the only reason we
were able to raise money my self-worth
still hinges on how fast we grow and
that definitely helped with that so this
this is the singular reason we are on we
are where we are today
so my parting words are don't leave
growth to chance guy
only blows a chance reverse-engineer
this this worked for us and it will work
for you thank you cool the first
question is from Carrie who says talk
description said you did it all without
Facebook ads is that true no paid ads
ads at all how did people find out about
you it's not true that we've used no
paid ads at all but all the paid ads
we've used have sucked like we've still
not figured out how to spend money
successfully and profitably like even
the second question is what's our tack
whenever we try and spend money cost us
like five thousand dollars to acquire a
customer we've not figured out paid
acquisition at all how did how did
people find out about us I mean as we
brought up like we did a lot of these
events we did a lot of partner
promotions we did a lot of intentional
marketing to get people to find our
product so we had a free plan we had a
free plan that got a lot of people to
sign up and every single year we kept
getting better and better at converting
our free users to paying users like
right now we're at about a little over
5% conversion from free to paid and
we've kept growing that number every
single time so converting free users the
big strategy affiliates and partners or
a big strategy also when you use
teachable you end up creating a website
that you in turn have other students
coming to that says powered by teachable
and that builds a kind of nice like
organic loop so so yeah most of this
happened without paid ads the paid ads
we did end up spending money on have not
been super successful strategically we
still have to learn how to spend money
to grow yeah and again like the fact
that we can't spend money to grow in my
mind is not a sign of strength at the
sign of weakness like we should learn
how to do that we've not been able to
thus far cool
the question is what's your CAC and LTV
I can talk more than algebra or LTV or
CAC is still as I said we don't rely on
paid a lot every time we run paid
acquisition or CAC comes super high but
our LTV right now is about
$800 and it's kind of trending to the
thousand dollar mark
so our LTV is looking good and it's
continuing to kind of ride off there and
how much you're on paid acquisition not
at all but we do want to one learn how
to get good at it and when we do it will
likely be pretty social heavy because
it's not a lot of search intent behind
what we're trying to find can you share
the everyday model online somewhere it's
awesome yeah I'll probably all like
tweeted out later or something that
might be helpful I'm happy to do that
how do you stress to ask your model to
figure out what's working and what's not
working and at what stage do you bite
the bullet and in a particular
strategy so the model I showed you right
there at the end of every month we would
basically look at what our assumptions
were and we'd look at what the reality
is and then accordingly decide what
needs to change so for instance partner
promotions are a great example because
they've worked really well for a while
and then they stopped working and a
certain point when we consistently
missed our partner promo line item for
months on an end we're like okay this
entire line item needs to go so the best
way of doing this was just again
applying this model looking at exactly
which part of it like which parts are
consistently missing the second example
is at some point next week we're gonna
kill our enterprise plan because our
enterprise plans still after all these
years has no product market fit to
distraction for the business we're gonna
kill our enterprise plan and again it's
it's the rigor of like looking at this
model and realizing that we've missed
our enterprise targets or like pretty
much every quarter that this whole thing
is not working
how has having a tweet go viral impacted
your life I don't know ask that but so I
had some tweet about hipster Brooklyn
reached 17 18,000 people liking it
on Twitter it's actually impacted my
life quite considerably there have been
a bunch of like random press outlets
reaching out we found three people to
apply for jobs at teachable because of
some random Brooklyn tweet going viral
so it has impacted it has impacted my
life a little but mostly it's just has
just been just been funny to look at
also does anyone want to ask any
questions like just in person it feels
weird to like read the stuff off a
screen right like anyone want to like
just raise their hand as well and ask
questions off off screen it's Andy still
at the company yes Andy is still at
Andy's led the company he's now working
on all our affiliated partner promotions
yeah he is not it he's not impressed
with the specific picture I chose of him
though but anyone want to ask questions
like it again yeah
so whose question is you talked about
self-worth has have as having a
successful company change your
self-worth okay Wow honestly no like I
think like you're I forget where I read
this but you're always you're
realistically always going to be about
as happy as you are now like I don't
think external outcomes really truly
change it as much as I like to joke
about my self-worth being tied to how
fast we're growing I don't think so at
all if anything the biggest thing having
the business has added is it is really
the team I work with has made my life
more valuable it doesn't change my
self-worth but my life feels more
valuable for the team I get to work with
every single day
any questions in person yep
kind of
the his question is can you explain the
unique metric you had I didn't quite
understand it is that the RTBF okay so
one more time the rtbf was at the end
start of every month we would figure out
how fast we want to grow and then we try
and reverse engineer what are the growth
channels we already know are happening
because chances are you'll have organic
upgrades you'll have some level of
growth built in rtbf is the difference
between the two so in the example for
August 2015 we needed to add ten
thousand dollars eight hundred and ten
thousand eight hundred forty three
dollars but we only had about we didn't
have twenty eight hundred dollars
accounted for
this is a purely this is a very this is
only a revenue model we do expenses
separately like our finance team does
expenses our growth / marketing team
does revenue so organizationally
expenses are done by a different
Department and personally I was never
involved with that because I'm not very
good at that's spending money side of
things so ah all right we'll take one
last question here
so very good question the question is
how do you ensure that short-term RTBF
does not come at the expense of
long-term innovation you don't always
try and do short-term one-off webinars
to make the difference two-part answer
one is at a certain point it did and
that's when we realized we had to kind
of zoom out and start planning things
more in advance the second thing is
we've always kept product strategy out
of this so product strategy kind of
applies at a different level where we
try and think of strategy over a period
of years but revenue in a period of
months so the short answer is it
definitely has and that's when we
realize we have to zoom out but we also
tried the opposite where we tried like
kind of ditching this entirely and then
we went back to not growing so we still
found applying this was more good than
bad we just have to get to a point of
doing it further out in advance and
forecasting a year out as well but
that's a very good question because that
is definitely a risk you can fall into
but at that point chances are your
company's already worth something you've
already passed the like Minimum Viable
like this is gonna be a business level
all right cool guys this has been
awesome thank you for having me
[Applause]